this is a simple scenario that that we
we enabled and you can you can basically
go and generate a rigid for your site
you can enable the collaborative
translation powered feature in this and
it just generates a small piece of code
it's just a little piece of code that
you have to embed in your site and it
appears like this and you could have
customized it so this is Boston Public
Health Commission which is using that
this is the lake washington school
district that has you know they have
they've used it and i already translated
so you can see the translation i will
show you here as well so basically
translated the side and the nice thing
is as you navigate this side it keeps
translating it and in this case they are
not using the collaborative translation
feature so you're only seeing the
original sentence the original segment
but in this case they did use that
feature so you can you can see that
there are actually alternatives and
somebody that they had actually gotten
volunteers from the from from their
parents who have authority so they went
and they basically approved it now I
don't have authority on this site so as
an anonymous user all I can do is select
something or go report something I can
even edit it but it doesn't override
this authoritative translation but it
does give feedback to the to the
moderators or the translators that have
been anointed by the school and so that
way you're basically really providing
that both instant gratification to
people who really want to give the
feedback and know that pretty pretty
quickly this feedback is going to be
useful and then if I do have a role then
I can actually affect that change right
away so so Facebook by the way also
recently used are used are
technology to enable a similar type of
solution and you can see that there is
now a translate link that you can click
and that translates it translated that
and then I could right click on there
and you can see I already like
translated this one so you can either
enter enter a new one or since I had
translated earlier is showing me that
you know I had translated it this way I
don't know spanish so hopefully I did
the right thing bed so so again you know
that's another thing we're facebook had
already kind of used this model to help
localize facebook so now with by
combining machine translation with that
amazing social crowd like social graph
that they have they were able to really
make interesting things happen so there
are others that I think I think you can
the best way to use this is go put it on
a blog or site that you own and play
around with it and at the time once you
once you've translated it and you're the
owner you actually have the mechanism to
go and invite people and and do other
fun things with it so let's go back to
okay so I mean I showed you the actual
demo so I'm just going to walk through
this so you know that's kind of the
dashboard where you can actually bulk
approve or bulk edit translations as
well so I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on this but basically in the past
you know you had the empty place
republishing model where you know
microsoft knowledge base and a bunch of
other of our own internal partners use
so that that kind of results in this
right and then you had empty with post
editing which then resulted in something
like this and then we have dynamic mt
which we just saw an example of this is
without the collaborative piece and then
there is the collaborator
peace added to it and you ended up with
something like this which is great right
you're starting to push that
untranslated content then ultimately I
mean where I would like to see this go
and this is something that we are
enabling as well is where you can
publish something just empty for the
further parts that you would have
otherwise never published and but enable
it for the feedback so I mean one of the
downsides of just doing the budget based
MT is that search engines cannot index
you because it's being done with
JavaScript on the fly in this model you
actually are publishing a snapshot of
the machine translation but then giving
your community and your authoritative
users a mechanism to really continually
improve that and then periodically you
can go and republish this so that way
you have a complete solution for all
types of content within your within your
organization so that's you know the best
of the both worlds and you know it
really really helps the user ultimately
right like you're making people
understand what you want them to
understand so the takeaways right so
some some very small ones but very
important ones right so show
alternatives right so this it's it's
really a way of adding value to the user
and even the implicit feedback of being
able to pick between one versus the
other is really valuable and and then
that helps subsequent users right and
then ultimately in terms of
personalization you know pre-populate
say we have that essentially a cloud
translation memory that powers this
thing so pre populate that with what is
you know commonly translated in your
community or commonly repeated and that
becomes authoritative and then what we
notice is that users do train themselves
I mean a lot of people a lot of other
people have mentioned that here too they
will understand after a while the things
that this does translate well and so you
are helping them author stuff
differently too
in situations where they're writing
comments or I'm very very fascinated by
what's going to happen with Facebook
because there is an additional element
where I have a social network a social
graph of mine which has people who can
speak that language that I'm trying to
understand so suddenly you know if
somebody shares a link with me the el
barco link or something else right and
they want me to understand that they can
go and they have more motivation more
incentive to actually you know do that
for me right and Facebook has an API
right so use the Facebook Connect API
and and bring that social graph into
your applications so that you know on
your scenarios you are able to take
advantage of the of the social graph for
the user who's watching so um next steps
you can try the widget and some of these
sites our blog is a great place to read
more about this technology there is an
invite code that you need today which
will be going away in a few weeks but
you can use that you can learn more
about the technology and I think this
presentation will be available to so you
know there are things that I kind of
skipped over but there is probably
easier to read from the presentation so
the data that you are collecting from
this type of feedback right especially
the facebook data is it is something
that Microsoft is collecting or your
customer in this case Facebook is
collected so Facebook is a special
example so let's not yet look at
facebook let's look at all other
customers who are using CDF right
facebook is special because they also
have their own kind of infrastructure
that they have already built for the
collaborative pieces and so the way they
use this is a little bit different than
everybody else but for everybody else
there is basically there is something
that identifies you to the system as in
when you sign up to use the API there is
some identifiers that identifies you to
the API so that you know you're like
your volume limit all of that is unique
so when that happens when your community
starts making edits those edits flow in
in
to this collaborative translations
database but are associated with you
right with your site right i mean you
may have more than one identifier
because you may have like a legal side
of a technical side is over and when all
the metadata associated with that so
ratings authority votes from that
particular community all of that is very
specific to your community it doesn't go
beyond that identifier right so it's
almost like your little TN and the one
thing that does happen and this is kind
of in some ways it's it's a little bit
like Wikipedia in that if say somebody
translated a particular sentence a
particular way that has become an
alternative within your community and it
could become more than an alternative
depending on who it is in your community
that did this but that also becomes an
alternative for that particular source
sentence across all scenarios right and
as a scenario owner you can choose to
not show that or show that you can
choose to set some thresholds saying if
hundred people had chosen or are
submitted this alternative for this
particular search sentence then I want
it to be shown in my scenario so that's
kind of the dichotomy between what
content like what of the metadata is
relevant just to your scenario and then
how do all other scenarios using this
framework benefit from from each other
right so and the amine we don't make any
qualms at all about the fact that we
would we would like to use some of this
to train the engine to get better right
but in general the goal is basically
that as a scenario owner you get
complete control over what gets
displayed on your site so you can you
can do all kinds of customization in
terms of you know who your moderators
are who your translators are and again
like I said the widget that
showed you is a scenario we built and so
that uses live ID in order to make it
easier for people to not have to code
but if you have your own user management
mechanism you can just call the api and
have a lot more flexibility that data
sits in that in the in the in
essentially in the TM right so it are
you asking about what does the Microsoft
translator team yes so what Microsoft do
with the TM so they align text that have
been extracted from user generated
content I suspect you have a simple
question you got a long answer but well
I mean III I will maybe defer to Chris
on the technical parts of it but i think
we are basically we will be able to
train on some of that right like so but
as far as we are concerned you know we
are not leaning on the metadata right we
are just training on parallel text so it
may be sourced from like 40 different
scenarios right the same sentence might
have appeared in 40 different places
with you know the same alternative so we
can train on that that's what you wanted
to know it seems the widget assumes that
you're starting with a blank slate in
terms of a translation what if you have
a site that how it where there's already
some pages that have been translated and
they want to preserve that but you want
to get some help for the pages that you
never got time to translate I kind of
refer to it a little bit in that in how
we were moving that to expand to
encompass all the untranslated data
right you don't have to put the visit on
your entire site you can scope it so
that it only appears on some pages right
so that's that's one thing and then the
other thing is you know there's this
other functionality where you could pre
translate a page and publish it and then
only enable it for feedback and not have
dynamic translation on that page so you
can do both of those if you already have
like other content that you have already
translated you could also use you could
also basically push it into into the
cloud so that it becomes authoritative
for your site
you